as vladimir putin threatens to detonate
nuclear weapons and plunge the planet
into world war iii democrats in congress
are focusing on the truly pressing
issues like outlawing lynchings which
are already illegal
always have been and have not been a
major problem for at least 70 years
you see for much of the 19th and early
20th centuries lynchings were a serious
problem in the united states targeting
mostly black people but other races as
well notably italians who were the
victims of the largest mass lynching in
american history
during the 58 years that made up the
height of lynching in america an
estimated 4
467 americans were killed by lynch mobs
according to one academic study for
perspective that is four fewer people
over a 58-year period than were murdered
in just a dozen american cities just
last year
but democrats haven't passed any laws to
stop the historic killing going on right
now
probably because they themselves
unleashed the crime wave during the blm
and antifa riots of 2020.
at the same time that the house voted to
make lynching illegal again to make it
super duper illegal
senate democrats voted to enshrine a
sacred national right to lynch babies in
the womb
fortunately the senate democrats failed
by about 14 votes babies in pro-life
states are safe for now
but then again it's hard to say that any
of us are safe when an autocrat in
russia is threatening to unleash nuclear
holocaust in the world if he is not
allowed to proceed with his invasion of
a sovereign nation an invasion that our
own idiot leaders invited him to
undertake
while those same idiot leaders focus
their firepower on non-existent problems
and american babies what a time to be
alive
for now
i'm so glad you liked that clip now you
got to ring the bell ring the bell
subscribe get the notifications
especially this is what you really got
to do head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch your google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts do it right
now i'll wait
you got it out good
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]